today
rather has done really fascinating work
in multiple areas including this really
cool work on Bernoulli factories and you
know series of working online algorithms
today is going to talk about and
matching meets patching
all right thank you Paulo for the
introduction and thanks everyone for
coming to my talk uh and thanks to both
of you for having us here
it feels great to always give a talk at
some things to do
uh so today I'm going to talk about uh
when matching meets patching and how to
design optimal multi-stage allocation
and matching algorithms and some of the
applications of this technique shop
uh before jumping into my talk
I just wanted to say that this is based
on a series of joints work with my
collaboratory eating Frank who is
currently a poster at Microsoft research
in England eating is on the job market
this year and he's fantastic one
assistant 30 seconds advertising him
so if you have jobs he's looking for
jobs
all right so I have designed the talk so
that the talk is kind of a high level uh
mixture of high-level ideas and
technical details so whichever tribe you
belong to whether you are here to learn
about the model and the algorithm or you
really want to learn some of the
algorithmic constructs that you have uh
in this series of work hopefully the
attack has something to offer with that
introduction that means
jump you actually talk so this talk is
really about matching subfloor erythema
which is arguably one of the most
classic problems that has been studied
both in CS economics and operations and
in particular what I'm gonna look at is
the scenario where decision maker is
dynamically matching demand AKA service
request to supply AKA service providers
and with the agent of online
marketplaces and platform this Paradigm
has become a central operational task
just in a few applications maybe it
might be a little bit boring for this
audience
for example in a sponsored search you
have to match search queries to
advertisers that are willing to show
their ads to the users in video YouTube
advertising for example Impressions from
users should be at should be allocated
to advertisers
in ride sharing write request
should be allocated to drivers in cloud
computing Platforms in such as AWS jobs
should be matched to servers
in online food delivery we have orders
that should be matched to careers
uh online retail
we have all sorts of delivery requests
that should be matched to internal
fulfillment centers run by the retailer
and finally this is kind of a cool
modern application in digital Freight
Network shipping requests should be
matched to carriers that are happening
to do these jobs
so maybe I can spend an hour talking
about each of these applications but
definitely is not what I'm planning to
do instead I'm gonna look at one aspect
of these applications
which makes them quite different and
that's the allowance for latency so what
does that mean suppose the demand
requests are right
how long you can keep the demand rating
until you match it to a supply and when
you think about this allowing for
latency these applications
have quite different amount of allowance
for example your sponsor search things
are almost immediate when the search
code is arrived you have to match it to
another Trader immediately having said
that I heard from I called you at Google
when I was there that add decisions at
the bottom of the page are not finalized
until the user Scrolls down all the way
to the bottom of the page and that gives
a window for Google to
optimize the ad allocation decision but
let's take a look
but here there are some other
applications that there's actually
natural allowance for latency for
example in YouTube most of the others
are displayed maybe after a few seconds
when you start watching the video the
user comes and start watching a video
session and then 10 seconds after there
will be the first adapt to be displayed
so if you look at the interval of land
10 seconds there will be a lot of users
that the video has already started and
therefore the platform can pull those
requires and make uh same allocation
decision for all of them and then in
ride sharing and maybe in cloud
computing the things is a little bit
more relaxed for example if I have a job
that needs to be done on one of the AWS
virtual machines maybe I can wait for
under two minutes
in online food delivery I still
it's very relaxed if you wait for your
food for another 10 days it's fine and
for example Amazon can add one day to
its delivery time so that it makes this
operation way more profitable maybe this
is something that the company might
transfer
the point is in all these applications
when there is an allowance for
relationship whether it is organic or is
deliberately induced by the platform
they can do batching
so what does matching me imagine the
demand requests are arriving over time
the platform by introducing waiting
times are going to group these demand
requests together each group is called a
batch and then at the end of arrival of
a batch it's going to make what they
call a stage decision for all the demand
requests that are within that patch
so this is in contrast to what we
usually know as online decision making
where you make an on-flight decision for
a demand request the moment that the
demand arrives so here you wait until
you have a batch and then you make a
stabilized decision uh one for each
touch
as I said in some applications like
YouTube video advertising there is this
organic delay and therefore you
automatically have these batches
exogenously kind of given to the
platform
in some applications such as ride
sharing the platform induces this
battery so this is from Uber the website
over Marketplace website on the left
side you see the matching as you go
algorithm on the right side this is what
they really do which is the batch
matching practice
the rider arrives you can either
immediately match the writer to the
closest driver or you can wait a little
bit
let's start doing the batching until the
market is ticking off and then you do
the best matching given the pull of the
rider that you have
all right so definitely this comes at
the cost and that's
Rider ratings but still
if this is something that is acceptable
you can other platform can benefit and
make a better matching difference
so
why batching is helpful it's a very
simple question it in fact as you pull
the uh request the market becomes
thicker and therefore as a platform we
can make more anticipatory Decisions by
essentially bringing future into the
current decision
but I want to also argue that not only
it has other operational benefits for
example Amazon has reported that they
could reduce their waste by batching the
delivery requests together simply
because you know they will be less
number of packages they need to send out
to their expansion centers and in this
way not only you can make the allocation
more efficient we can also reduce other
what I call operational costs for
example in this case waste
uh however trivially it comes at the
cost and that's the latency so it's
really important to understand the
actual trade-off that you get between
batching and inefficient
so what do I mean by that as you have
more number of patches of a smaller
sizes
definitely you get closer and closer to
the online decision making and therefore
there will be more inefficiency in your
allocation decision
to just see two extremes if you look at
one extreme and you have one gigantic
patch that has all the demand requests
then you are going to make one
allocation decision for the entire
sequence and that gives you the best
machine you can hope for the in-home
inside optimal March
for their message you want to Target
On The Other Extreme case you have one
single vertex in each part
and that would be the case that we call
online decision making
right still this is going to be sort of
efficient but definitely not as
efficient as the inherent side of your
benchmark
and here's a question I'm trying to
address what would happen in the Middle
Ground regime when you have some limited
number of patches in particular given a
fixed number of patches can be really
characterized the efficiency performance
of
multi-stage matching or allocation
algorithms
so this is the informal question I'm
going to address in this talk uh and
sometimes I have been asked this
question how do you do the batching this
is not the address in this talk
I assume that the batches are given
exogenously and the question is from the
algorithmic perspective how the
algorithm designer is going to improve
the algorithm to make the allocation
decision better given the patches that
are arriving over time
yeah
[Music]
who kept the first person and waiting
until the end of the batch
maybe maybe just you have a bunch of
notes that are available at the time but
the moment they are about to make a
matching decision for all of them at the
same time
foreign
by revisiting some classic models in
online packing linear programming maybe
for again for this crowd I don't need to
explain a lot but let me do it anyway
uh imagine you have an instance of a
packing LP where the packing constraints
are already there so they're given
offline and then you have LP variables
that are arriving over time
that's the online aspect
maybe one canonical example of this
third is the seminal work of Corporation
online by partake matching uh which is
basically the following problem we have
a biparticraft g between two sides the
supply side the offline side denoted by
V the demand side the online site
denoted by U
the demand knows arrive over time once
the vertex are right this will reveal
the incident adjust to the offline side
and now the goal of the online decision
maker is to make a matching decision
basically to which available offline
vertex match this arriving online node
so I have to maximize the size of the
matching at the end and the goal is
really coming up with a matching that is
as close as the in-houseight optimal
matching which is the maximum magic when
you know the entire graph
there are other variants of this sort of
online by project applications that have
been necessary in the literature for
example I can mention the vertex rated B
matching in which you have a capacity on
each offline node let's say BJ initial
flow node comes with a score rate and
the goal is to find the online matching
that maximum total rate at the end
there's also online budgeted allocation
also known as artwork problem where
basically our search queries are having
over time the other traders in the given
budget once the search query arrives all
the advertisers are revealing the beats
that they have for that search query and
the goal is to allocate the search
queries to Advertiser so as to maximize
the total collected beat while you're
respecting advertisers
there are also other variations some
people in the audience have worked on
those for example iterated matching
history disposal voltage optimization or
configuration allocation online
assortment so on and so forth but they
are all derivatives of this very basic
model
for the purpose of this talk I'm going
to focus on vertex related B matching in
particular assuming that the capacity is
equal to one
and I'm also going to only look at
fractional matches basically the
algorithm can make fractional Solutions
uh you can think of the large budget
version where the algorithm is forced to
make integral allocations and then there
are standard independent runways
rounding together with concentration
bounds that can give you the same
results
uh almost the same results for the
larger but for the purpose of this stuff
I'm just going to look at the capacity
one and fractional match
so this feature was really about online
allocation so we are going to diverge by
assuming a new mode of arrival which is
what they call the batch arrival we have
KS stages
as at each stage a new batch consists of
a bunch of demand nodes arrive and
reveal their incident that just to the
offline set for example if K is equal to
2 this is going to be the first batch
they arrive you see the edges then
they'll be the second bus they arrive
you see that just K is equal to four
we'll have four arrivals I make no
assumption on the sides of these patches
how these graphs are formed Etc you
should think of it as the worst case
instant there is an oblivious adversary
that is picking these batches and how
they are connected to the offline set
all right
so what we are going to do is coming up
with a multi-stage fractional matching
algorithm basically at every stage K
once the batch UK arrives and you get to
see the edges EK you want to pick a
point x in 0 1 to the power e k a
feasible matching for data stage so that
basically you satisfy the matching
constraints on the online side and on
the offline sets
meaning that every online node should be
matched out with one of my node that's
the first time strings and then defining
by J to be the consumption level or the
matching degree of each I'll find out at
the beginning of the batch K you want to
have a consumption that is that most one
minus y j on each offline
this is a physical that much yes so all
these problems certainly that the graph
the adversary fix is oblivious it's not
adaptive but the battery
um
which means how they how the online
notes are divided
batching being
because
is
so let's say you have keyboard to
um
because the second part is basically
just the second verse you can decide on
that software that means that message
and decides on the edge so I'm about to
diversity channels
foreign
all right so the goal is to match with
the total weight of the matching at the
end and we are trying to ask those as
possible to the doctor in hindsight
Benchmark the optimum the maximum weight
match
all right so yes
so the YJ depends on at time K depends
and do you know what why zero is uh
so there is no annotation
okay
[Music]
so basically at the beginning of the
game when before the first message
and then you make allocation decisions
then you have to update by J if you go
to Second refers
oops
so
um you need to verify the magic to
quantify a different algorithms in the
study as you probably have guessed
algorithmic at the notion of completion
uh so what does competitive ratio mean
let me Define this number gamma K to be
the best competitive ratio that can be
achieved by multiple algorithm
and what does that mean so fix the
multi-sh function algorithm like the one
that I showed you earlier I'm looking at
the expected weight of the algorithm
divided by the weight of the optional
offline solution and then I'm looking at
the worst case quantity you can get
among all the problem instances that you
might have so that will be the
competitive issue of that particular
algorithm and Gamma key is Simply the
Best competitive issue you can get using
a fractional algorithm
K is a number of stages the number of
batches number of patches
think of k equal to 3 you have three
stations
correct
go to one kind of related to negative
question so gamma K is going to be equal
to one this is the optimum
if k equal is equal to the number of
online nodes and also add this
assumption that passes are equal to one
this is going to be the fully online
node so basically gamma K is going to be
the whatever you can get in online
matching when you have K number of
arrivals
all right and the question is really
what would happen in this Middle Ground
resident case greater armor and let me
tell you what you can do for example
first of all any greedy algorithm
Integrity allocation algorithm is going
to be half completed but there's a
greedy algorithm in this context mean at
every stage just find the maximum
weighted matching given the remaining
capacities and options
and if you concatenate these marchings
together you're going to end up with a
half competitive algorithm
this is fairly easy to show but in fact
you can easily do better than that why
because you can just pretend that the
batch has arrived in an online fashion
even though you have these batch
arrivals just pick some arbitrary
ordering over vertices in one batch and
run an online algorithm on this instance
and for this particular problem we're
expected to be matching uh there is a
variance variant of the balance
algorithm that is going to be one minus
one over e competitive and let me
explain 10 seconds to tell you what what
does this algorithm do imagine a new
online vertex arrives
so this algorithm is going to
continuously and fractionally allocate
infinite sum of infinite decimal amount
of uh resource to the offline node that
maximizes this quantity
WJ times 1 minus e to the power by J
minus 1.
they should really think of it as the
score that you give to each offline
vertex which is a combination of weight
and the current consumption level
and then after allocating DX amount it's
going to update the varages and continue
to do that until you get to the end
and as it turns out this is going to be
the optimal competitive algorithm in the
online
there are several other works that think
about multi-esearch computer
optimization so he'll have the beautiful
paper who is sitting in the audience
thinking about the edge arrival version
none of them is directly related to this
so I don't want to go through them but I
will be happy to chat about how some of
other works might give you alternative
algorithms none of them is going to be
able to beat my authorities
yes another question um it's even that I
see the bash and I see all the ideas why
wouldn't I just pick the offline optimal
matching for for that batch right
because
I see okay let's fix the maximum weight
matching uh in the current subgraph
given the remaining capacity and that
gives you a half
you need some sort of hedging and this
is
how to do the history
especially like the weights are on the
offline mode this is not the online
all right
so now I can Define my formal research
question in the middle technology with K
that's a stupid data record on one
batches what's going to be the optimal
competition ratio that can be achieved
by a fraction
so we basically show the matching upper
lower bounds the gamma K is going to be
equal to this quantity 1 minus 1 minus 1
over K to the power of K
so the result consists of a lower bound
and an upper bound on the upper bound
saw it basically shows that instance is
actually using the batching structure
such that no online algorithm whether
fractional or integral can do better
than one might one wise or k to the
power K in terms of competitive ratio
and then we have kind of a interpretable
simple algorithm that can obtain this
competitive range
K is equal to two you get three fourth
approximation if K is equal to three you
get 19 over 27 this is a strictly larger
than 1 minus 1 over e as long as you
have uh constantly many batches you
obtain constant improvements over the
number of minus one over e uh it
converges to one life already from above
as K goes to Infinity this becomes
basically one minus one over e I'm
somehow suggesting that the benefit of
the batching exponentially degrades as
the number of patches grow I would say
this might be an artifact of uh versus
analysis and maybe with other uh forms
of input instances and arrival you might
be able to get different interpretations
my understanding of what's Happening
Here is basically if you have an
algorithm and you let the algorithm to
have look ahead Maybe by looking at case
stages in future then even with constant
look ahead you are going to get constant
improvements over what you could get in
there
optimal flag
right so I get like
[Applause]
so even if I like delay my things like
my 10 minutes I'm gonna Escape
when I was Consulting Uber back in 2019.
and there what they wanted to do I think
I can review because it will joined for
a bit I mean I mean revealed that two
days ago in abortion yeah it should be
closer to me you know so yeah
[Music]
so there basically
they they really want to incorporate
just one eye to our future let's say
there's just one stage coming after so
there's some writers that they have
already accepted their price codes and
then there are some writers that they
have opened up but they haven't accepted
the price codes so you have this set of
candidate writers but they are it's not
yet finalized and the question is how do
they make the matching decision for the
current launch given this uncertainty
about the second one no I understand
that and that's that's how you should
really fit this particular result to the
right Channel
about your result is that you just show
these results
it's not that helpful because for those
case k goes to infinity and you just go
back
it depends on how to define the Horizon
right so for example it's more like I
guess you're saying it's more like you
would be doing
the only local allocation in some sense
so let's say I just want to see the
effect of one book ahead versus green
right so you want to understand how much
longer that is
indicator
and in fact actually even with that one
look ahead you can see huge improvements
when you run these algorithm practice I
can tell you
what we say about the sizes of the
batches it's flexible
so the only the only part of the problem
is found that we try about this K it
should be fixed so I'm trying the hands
of the other thing on that fronts but
rather diversity puts into the badge is
flexible so this happens
very small patches
or questions
uh Daniel okay actually sorry I have a
related question like it seems like kmt
like K and the Horizon are intimately
related
and that's not entirely clear here to me
because
yeah so T is going to be going to record
okay and that's the only assumption
a meaningless quantity by itself I'm not
sure because yeah
then like per hour you're batching 60
times
but per day you're batching 1440 times
right but then the question is why are
you competing with the best in high
definition for the day
because that might be too good of a
benchmark to achieve so maybe you're
better off to just like blue clouds and
here is you can try to see if I I can't
look at how much I can get improved over
that experience and that basically what
we showed you in something I think the
way I think is key is meaningless
Horizon feel free to get new cars in the
system right
sure uh at the same time I would say you
should not use this machine for
long-term operation should really think
of it as a local uh decision making so
let's say in the next 30 seconds
I'm gonna improve the matching algorithm
and then I'm saying okay so there will
be probably three batches here
earlier I was ignoring the effect of the
second and third batch and what I'm
going to do in the first batch now I'm
going to Google
but really this is this doesn't fits
completely well in the right check
application
uh how many video ads I would say this
is actually pretty good in the sense
that you know there maybe in the 10
minutes I'm just gonna try to see how
much improvement I get some of the ads
are going to be shown as units five
minutes six so there you might end up
with four batches five batch at a time
in the next 10 minutes I try to make the
matching decision as optimized as
possible using this thing
the lower bound
that's a big box size or it's something
yeah and therefore this is
[Music]
is
yeah so and uh if this and maybe an open
question like whether this bond is
achievable using integral matches yeah
that's the one of the other problems
right next
for k equal to 2 we can actually 3 4 but
4K even equal to three I don't know how
to do it
still 99.
all right
cool uh so I saw him pointed out we are
looking at fractional matchings and we
can actually extend this result to
vertic related B matching when you have
capacity is not equal to one uh and
budgeted allocation assortment Etc and
the same results uh can be extended to
the integral allocation when you have
large budgets you have a recent paper
which is focusing on video advertisement
allocation in applications such as
YouTube and there what we really do is
solving the multi-fetch configuration
allocation I'm going to spend a few
minutes if time permits at the end of my
talk talking about that variation
okay
cool so
uh how much time okay I have
I have a calculator
so besides the number you saw in the
previous slide I personally am excited
about this series of words because of
this new algorithmic idea that in
introducing literature and that is kind
of using convex programming to make
allocation decisions in online
algorithms
I'm particular what we are proposing is
using what I call a regularized convex
programming allocation in particular
polynomial regular economics program
allocation to solve this problem
so what we basically do in this paper is
we identify a unique sequence of
polynomials of decreasing degree where
the polynomial is the largest degree
appears in the first stage the second
largest happening the second essay so on
and so forth and then we this
polynomials to uh
regularize the greedy algorithm the lp
that you can write for max weight
matching the one that you pointed out
to introduce a structured balance as an
allocation
and then the interesting part is
because you're using Comics programs you
can actually use convex duality
to decompose the graph that you have in
every stage into some sort of
decomposition and then we use the graph
decomposition in order to set up a
linear program based Primal dual
analysis to get the box
the basically this paper is kind of
making this connection between convex
programming and online algorithms on the
design of the algorithm site and also we
use the convex duality in order to come
up with the Primal dual analysis for the
lp that you have the LP for the maximum
weighted match
I love you
you have to sit in my truck uh yes
that's the remaining half of my turn
the rest of the talk I'm gonna show you
how you can design this kind of balance
allocation to think convex programming
and then I'm gonna
touch the question like if I assume that
was a size one
give me this result you should also okay
okay
cool uh yeah and then if time periods
I'm going to show you how to highlight
the pattern using the graphic card which
I try to discuss the step as a little
bit and give yourself
let me start by some simple examples
in particular I'm going to start with
this very simple example when I have two
stages there are four offline notes
there there is the four online nodes uh
two RF at the first stage and imagine
there is a complete graph between the
first stage batch and the offline
so I don't think it's going to shoot you
two edges in the second message you
don't know which of the two of finals is
going to pick by the adversary so maybe
the best thing you can do is really
having a fully balanced allocation
by
picking a fraction matching that uses
every of my nodes with the actual degree
equal to half and that gives you the
competitivity of three books
so here it seems you know balancedness
is going to be helpful to obtain a
meaningful algorithms
here are two questions do I always want
to pick a maximum weight matching or
maximum matching in first stage and the
second question is do I always want to
have a fully balanced allocation in the
first system
so let's see the answer to this question
so for example in this example I have
two nodes
uh the weight of the person is W plus
Epsilon the weight of the second node is
w
if I go with the maximum vertex rated
matching I'm going to always allocate
the aligner to this guy so therefore the
Iverson can screw me very easily by
shooting this Edge
therefore if algorithm only gets half
but in fact if you again do the balance
allocation you can get competitive ratio
of three-fourths
do I always want to be balanced let's
see another example uh I have W1 W2
everyone is much larger than W2 this
time I'm going to go with the balance
allocation
again the competitive ratio is not going
to be more than half because you're
losing half of the potential of your
allocation
but it turns out that it's really
careful allocations on these two online
nodes you can obtain a competitive ratio
of three four tickets in fact all you
need to do is to allocate proportional
to the weight so if the allocation on
the first car is W1 divided by W1 plus
W2 and the remaining is on the second
guy then you end you can show that you
are going to end up with a completed
ratio of three points
so from this example I hope I could
convince you that you need to do hedging
to be robust against an adversary that
is designing the second stage and third
decision and so forth but at the same
time you want to have a structured
hedging
that incorporates the graph that is
revealed that every sh together with the
weights on the offline side
so that you can use all the information
that you have in your business at the
same time the fact that there will be
some number of edges some number of
stages that would be remained throughout
the race
so here are a couple of questions how
can I formalize the notion of balance
matching when you have a general graph
and how can I impose it by an algorithm
and how can I analyze that so I'm going
to hit the
[Music]
two Web different Stone by answering
both of these questions through the same
thing and that brings us to
regularization which is really a
systematic approach
to incorporate balances
what I'm going to do is I'm going to use
a strict context Regulators in the
objective of degree algorithm to
incorporate regularization
so let me tell you exactly what's the
algorithm that uses regularization I
actually wanted to point out that you
see regularization all over the place
across different corners of computer
science operations and economics for
different purposes but somehow the
fundamental reason behind all of them is
the same thing for example in supervised
learning we use regularization to avoid
overfitting which is some sort of
robustness against these specifications
in data in economics you use again
regularization to have fairness in
allocation to have balance things
in finance for diversification
portfolios during online learning we saw
in the previous Workshop that you can
use regularization to have online
learning algorithms at a robust adversal
attacks I think mechanism design
regularization will help you to make
algorithms robust to specifications in
types the report of the text
and then these techniques some of these
techniques can be used to transform
algorithms intubation instead of
compatible mechanics I have a paper on
that that Paulo mentioned I I wanted to
point out that this is a very
interesting concept and it appears in
several Corners I think it's
regularization in general needs uh to be
more steady than better understood
so the way I'm going to use it in my
talk is the following just as a recap of
the notation UK is a set of vertices
however the stage k e k is a set of
edges
and now I'm going to set up the LP for
maximum weighted matching that you saw
in previous Slide by adding this
regularization tag
let me open this term they basically
have a summation over all offline nodes
where each time this score is rated with
WJ and then you have this function f of
K you should really think of it as a
integral of a monotone increasing
function of little Earth that as its
inputs gets the final allocation level
of my vertex chain
and then the rest is the positive that
you have for fractional matching in a
stage scale
so you set up this convex program and
then you can solve it
for example you can use the exponential
function convex polynomials negative
entropy as choices for function capital
F of K
and let me actually show you one
choice
that answers a last question and
reinvent an existing wheel in the Deep
kitchen
as a reminder this is a balance
algorithm
now look at the special case of our
problem where you have basically batches
of studies one only one vertex Arab at a
time and suppose I'm looking at the
regularized max weight matching when my
regularizer is basically the integral of
the function e to the power of Z minus
four
all right
and I'm using the same regular is there
term at all their stitches
now if you carefully look at the convex
we're going to take the gradient with
respect to the variable y j the final
water level of each offline node then
you notice that the gradient is
basically the function W J times 1 minus
e to the power by J minus
1. all right so if I give you a convex
program and you want to solve it what
would you do you run a first order
Matrix
one first order method we can run this
coordinate asset which is the phonics so
you calculate the gradient you find the
coordinates that has the maximum
Improvement and you move a little bit
along that chord so the balance
algorithm is basically coordinate asset
when you run it on this convex row
that answers your question
so there is this deep College
the catch uh
algorithm is using the same regularizer
at every Stitch
and now let's think about it
fifth if we start from the last stage do
you really want to do any hedging the
obvious answer is no because in the last
message you just want to pick the
maximum weight matching given what you
have done in the previous stages
now you go one stage earlier you know
one stage is coming so probably you want
to have more balancedness in your
allocation you want to increase the
amount of hedging
and now we go to two essays earlier you
know two two stages are going to come
after me so again you want to increase
the energy and so on and so forth so
somehow you want to have a algorithm
design technique that increases the
amount of hedging as you go to earlier
stages
so
it's always like the maximum weight
nothing it's just that you want to just
spread it out
I know so if you have a uniform weight
what you're saying is correct but if you
have vertic face you are not always
fitting the maximum way too much
because yes with my yes perturbing the
wisdom unique maximum it's like it's a
unique maximum and it's very much
all right uh so here's the question how
did you increase the energy effect
yeah yeah so so then if I have an unwed
to set thing I might not necessarily
need to change the headset accordingly
that gives you a way to find a proper
distribution of our integument
changing the hedging is up changing that
distribution I'm changing the regulator
changing that information
for two essays you don't
but for kids that they actually need
different distributions
yeah so so with the hedging being the
most at the top
of my questions
all you need to do is increase the
degree of the body number and this is so
basically uh the one way to think about
it is as you have a polynomial of larger
degrees somehow you have more aggressive
term in your objective and that
introduces more hedging uh and in fact
this is what you've seen also as you
designed this algorithm so what I'm
going to do is using these polynomials
and change their degrees I will go to
later in stages in order to decrease the
amount
uh imagine the following polynomial at
least F of K at the stage 71 minus 1
minus x divided by K minus K to the
power K minus K so this is the function
that converges to e to the power x minus
one from Below
and now certainly if it's just maybe the
integral of the function and I'm going
to use these regulations
if you're wondering where are they
coming from
uh they're actually coming from the
recursive backward functional equation
and this regards the back of the
background function I'm pushing
something that came out of our analysis
framework and then the initial point in
the last exercise I already knew that
solution for the last definition we
don't need the regulations are so the
function should be constant zero either
by floating data solving this you get
these three points of problems and we
believe this is actually a unique
solution uh I mean this is the
limitation for this recovery regulation
I kind of think this is actually the
unit algorithm that Activity The Right
company which is
like set cable myself thinking
increasingly
in other words
as you said K is equal to that gives me
like one step organization mean
s that you are very competing yourself
against like an optimal offline within
this like window that you have like
feedback so if you are going with from
Kpop three to three four four so then
you are considered you want to be cool
because when you cross this so important
so so you're making your finished worker
stronger yeah
then and therefore
eating but uh can I like you
if you have any money
this is
I thought you said okay
but in practice when you run these so if
you're running forever so you want to
restart um
this is exactly what the two refers
algorithm in the Uber applications
function F1 is going to be used in the
first stage that the polynomial with a
degree K you will have a degree K
regulator in second or third so on and
so forth and then the last episode you
basically run liquidity you pick the
maximum weighted matching in the
remaining instance
is
let me give you a counter example okay
so ranking for audio
but then there is a
hidden fraction of algorithms that's the
probability that's created when we write
each number
and those properties are not the same as
what was happening
so I already gave you two fractional
algorithm for only purpose magical team
performance is
foreign
[Music]
support us
this is
uh
let's not claim the Philippines
actually I don't believe it is
great
cool so uh in the remaining the five
years I tried to expect some of the main
ideas how to analyze these arguments
uh so the main analysis setting is just
as Prime module framework for the linear
program of optimum offline so on the
left hand side you see the primer which
is the matching on the entire graph and
on the right hand side it's a dual LP
which is kind of a Vertex color so you
have one dual Viber Alpha I first online
node one dual beta J for each offline
node you're minimizing formation of
alpha I beta J such that you cover every
Edge and covering every age essentially
means that the sum of the duals on that
air should be at least the weight on the
offense
the primary solution is going to be the
solutions that you get from this capital
K number of convex programs and now if I
can support this solution using a dual
that is approximately feasible and has
the same objective as the primer then
this is going to be a certification for
approximate optimality of the pack
basically my goal is to call with a dual
Solutions such as the change in the
Primal and changing the door I mean the
entire Primal object and entire dual
objects are equal to each other and my
dual is approximately feasible basically
Alpha and beta J are non-negative and
for every i j Alpha plus beta jigs at
least gamma K times
if you have such a certification then
you have approved for exam okay
competitive ratio of your output
and the name of the game is really how
to design such a Dua
and here we go with the graph the
competition
as it turned out uh from the convex
program that you have for every stage
you can come up with a particular graph
decomposition let me tell you what does
this graphic composition look like to
answer making the earlier question
this is basically the sub graph that you
have in a stage kit imaginary solve the
convex program and I look at all the
edges where excess star kij is a
strictly greater answer basically every
single edge that is used somehow by the
switch of the convex version
then we looked at the connected
components of this subgraph
and these are going to be these pairs
that you see on different slides
the moment that you have special
decomposition then some properties come
out the first property is what I call
uniform you can actually show for each
of these pairs if you look at any
offline nodes
this quantity which is the weights times
1 minus beta F at the final allocation
of that node is going to be constant
among all these nodes
so you can basically assign this number
the uniformity concern to each of these
pairs the second quantity the second
property is monotonicity which basically
says that there will be no Edge in your
actual graph from the online side of a
pair to the offline side of another pair
if the uniformity constant of this pair
is a smaller than the uniform constant
of the other and finally there is a
property we call it saturation in the
paper which basically says that all of
the online order are going to be fully
matched in this stage except everything
that is in the last one with the
smallest uniformity constants
if you're wondering where is this Beast
coming from it actually comes from the
kkt condition so you can really write
down the KKK conditions of the convex
program and by playing around with that
you can improve all this profit sorry
you're using this permission to come up
with conversation
so we use the KK no so the graphic
competition is just this uh find the
software and discard the components that
that is
very satisfied
and how to show that these satisfied
this property is indicator
this is kind of like much of yours I
mean all I do is I finally stop that and
I then observe these things
and and these properties were only for
the particular regularizer that you
choose or like more generally great so
uh this properties hold for any convex
function that you put here but
definitely you get a diff I mean the
property
yeah
do you know like a commentatorial
algorithm to find out
so the undated version when all the
vertices are equal to each other is an
example of a dollar that knows
decomposition which is for General
graphs but if you look at the special
case for bipartic graphs then this is
what is known as matching a skeleton so
he has a paper that has used the
matching the skeleton in different
contexts and it was in this paper of
Ashish oil and others back in 2012 and
there there is actually commercial way
of coming up with the color of the
composition it basically is a recursive
algorithm that finds the most hyper
matchable pair first the decomposition
pair has the maximum uniformity brings
that part out and the recursively
continue for the general conference
program I don't know I try to believe
it's hard uh I didn't actually know that
I was hoping to get it throughout the
competition from the general dates uh I
was trying to communicable algorithm I
couldn't I ended up saying that actually
you can get the properties directly by
looking at the future
all right uh and these because the
compensation give you all you need in
order to have the rights to our
Construction in particular I'm gonna
construct my daughters in the phone
number initialize all the alphas and
beta J's to be zero
then when a batch arrives find the
structural decomposition that we saw in
the previous slide
now for each online node look at the
composition pair that the online node
belongs to and set Alpha right to be the
uniformity constant of that pair and
then on the offline side update the beta
J by adding this term Delta beta J which
is really the difference between the
weight of that offline node and the
uniformity constant multiply by how much
allocation that of the vertex drops in
that stage
for the experts in the audience this is
a higher generalization of the Primal
dual framework that we have seen for
other online bipartate allocation
problems including
AdWords and verticated online matching
so this is kind of extending that
primordial framework in a
kind of different way to batch arrival
when you have multiple number of patches
and to this day I still have a hard time
to really see why Comics program was the
right way of looking at things and could
get us this extension
and I'm still exploring some of the
things that you can do with the convex
programming
some of X stars like like I guess this
gives you like approximate feasibility
but you did multiply by that you would
have like full feasibility correct in
order to ensure My Limo Bond
so that we're changing the Primal is
equal to the change in the door
the sharing point is why did I construct
my idea of 10.1 like this by this is not
one because this is going to be better
for dual feasibility
but then you don't want to have a very
large node
in particular you want to have a dual
that the dollar objective because the
private object because it turns out that
by obtaining that way you can ensure
that every at the end of every stage
using the uniformity and saturation the
change in the primary objective and
changing the duology
and therefore at the end the Dual
objective on primological again
but the main technical demo is showing
the Dual feasibility and in fact what we
show is at the end of each essential you
look at Alpha plus summation of these
Delta Data from the previous stages then
this is gonna already be enough for
showing the opportunities
fix this is
I don't know I mean this is the optimal
for this particular band
how much allocation you put on edge
energy just this one locally for that
top graph that you obviously
yeah so there is the information from
the early annotation is encoded in
budgets and
obviously don't see the future
but the proof is you need to use the
monetary and uniformity and then there
is this induction step that is needed
for finishing this proof from that
induction instead of the recurrency
functional equation uh comes out and
that gives you the polynomials that
change
so I'm running around to be happy to
talk about more details of this profile
so hopefully I could come with you
something interesting is happening here
uh I have maybe one or two more minutes
all right so let me let me let me
summarize and then I'm gonna discuss a
little bit about two papers
uh so what we saw is basically an
algorithm which is based on this idea of
regularized Max State matching and how
this is going to give you the optimal
competitive algorithm when you have uh
multiple batches and you're in the
multi-stage allocation uh checking
there are some open problems that come
out of this board uh maybe the most
important one is something that sahi is
mentioned if I remember correctly which
is the following can be sure for the
integral version of the same problem the
optimal competitive ratio is gamma k
and the challenge is really
the challenge that uh is a rounding
challenge in the sense that I have the
fractional algorithm that works
perfectly one naive thing to do is
independently round digital at every
stage but this is not gonna work you
really need to correlate the decisions
this is something that we have learned
from the entire literature online
matching and for this particular problem
it's really not clear how to uh do that
and let me tell you another reason this
is a challenging but interesting open
proper if you can come up with another
algorithm for this problem that will
give you another algorithm for integral
version of online by portrait matching
and today I only know one algorithm for
that strategic
so
I have no idea how we can incorporate
something like ranking into this convex
programming idea and trying to copy that
algorithm so this seems to be
interesting and my conjecture is you
know whether algorithm copy it should
there algorithm that in the special case
when you have batches of 31 give you
ranking
otherwise you're one of the very top
three smartest people that I've seen in
my life because many people try to find
an alternative algorithm on a bipartite
matching that they could
good
for the weighted version again I think
the uh there is this algorithm which is
generalization of ranking for vertex
rates that again I I would say in the
special case you should boil down
okay uh and uh you know you can think of
the stochastic measure of the same
problem with known an unknown
distribution I think these are a little
bit more boring uh
because somehow you can use
agriculture type of results in many of
these settings especially on the large
budget therefore uh I'm really
interested to know what would be an
interesting model that has something new
compared to the previous literature
and there are other models that can
capture the efficiency between latency
and efficient they capture the trade-off
between the latency and efficiency I'm
curious to know whether there is a legit
model in this case uh one extension we
have is the multi-stage configuration
allocation this is the recent paper so
the idea was in applications such as
video advertising
uh sometimes there are uh
constraints that you would like to have
among the ads that you show to the same
user that has started watching a video
for example just name a few frequency
capping the no competitor or diversity
constraint these are really things that
people care in uh practice if Nikes are
displayed to a user in one video you
don't want to show the Adidas ad in the
same video
and there are many ways that you can
incorporate this constraint but there is
a very clean way of incorporating this
through what I call the configuration so
you can define a set of configurations
that should be assigned to a starting
video and the configuration is going to
tell you how many Impressions each
Advertiser is going to get and what's
the price for impression that Advertiser
should pay and now the question is how
would you allocate these configurations
to video sessions as they arrive but
then because I because of the reason I
told you there is this natural element
for latency so the question would be how
would you do this in a multi-face
fashion
but as it turns out the techniques I
told you cannot be extended easily there
simply because no graphic composition
exists in that domain
and at the beginning I thought this
cannot be extended then we tried hard
and there is a generalization of the
legalized complex programming allocation
which I'm going to call it price level
regular economics programming
application which essentially do the
regularization at every price per
impression level
and Aggregates among all the prices in a
small fashion and it turns out that
gives you the right algorithm for this
generalization this generation is
written off that includes every single
online property application but I know
of
and the second one we discussed is in
the middle of the talk so basically you
can think of the two such as stochastic
matching where you have some
distribution knowledge about the second
stage and now you want to make a
decision we can eye towards the future
you can even simulate the future using a
simulator but you don't know the exact
realization of the sub graph in the
second sh and now the problem runs with
the realm of approximation algorithms
how would you pick a matching in the
first stage so that you maximum is the
expected sides of the matching uh at the
end in the second stage you always want
to pixel Max so much so because of how
which matching should you pick in the
first stage given this distribution of
knowledge you have it turns out do you
think the distribution knowledge you can
actually do better than the three-fourth
approximation algorithm so we are now
ready for this uh
problem which gives you one minus one
over e plus one over e s squared
approximation
0.78 something uh but I think the idea
of kind of like using the distribution
competing with the option one line this
time right an optimal offline and having
improved approximation is something that
might be applicable to other products
and I told you about eating eating is
going to be on the job market with my
collaborator in almost all of these
papers the last paper the Twisted of the
Catholic matching is the collaboration
the leading and I'm in trouble that's
found
and with that I would like to conclude
my chunk uh thank you so much for your
attention I'm sorry for
keeping you from lunch a little bit
later
all right
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]